all right so imagine you're a teenager
he'll our analytics tell us that you
probably are and imagine you build
something bigger than yourself bigger
than a youtube channel or a twitch page
and millions of people around the world
know who you are that was the case for
hex in the green wall optic gaming a
brand synonymous with Call of Duty until
just recently when it all ended and
today I'm gonna tell you that story
[Music]
2017 it really feels like a long time
ago at eSports doesn't it that was an
era where the outside world finally saw
eSports as a way that they could make
money you'll remember that this was the
time where external funding sort of
started to creep its way into eSports
orgs were going out and finding
investors to help them buy slots in
leagues like the LCS or the overwatch
League and that was allowing them to pay
people extra money no this created a
kind of chain reaction inside of eSports
because when the top works like liquid
or cloud 9 go ahead and get some outside
investment then you need to find your
own to follow suit because how are you
supposed to compete for players or
market share or extra clout if you don't
have the cash to do it in 2017 the
overwatch League was starting and so was
the franchised LCS and these leagues had
massive price tags on their slots and
that increased the need for these teams
to go out and get some extra money and
so going back to optic that's exactly
what Hector Rodriguez you probably know
him as hex dick he went up and got some
cash to compete in this increasingly
competitive eSports world and so that's
where my story today begins with a
company called Texas eSports Holdings
that eventually decided to invest in
optic gaming that company and Hector
made a deal for some shares in optic and
Texas eSports Holdings ended up making a
company called infinite eSports that
would house optic within their company
and it was with that money that optic
could now afford a franchise spot in the
LCS and the Houston outlaw spot in the
overwatch league now it's easy to see
these big flashy numbers and new logos
and new jerseys as a positive thing for
eSports org and honestly on the surface
they really are but it's important to
sort of look under the surface as well
when these mergers happen it's not all
roses for these companies the fact is on
that day optic was sold to infinite that
meant that they had majority control and
hex no longer could make decisions on
behalf of his company the point I'm
trying to make here is that when these
things happen although these
organizations get the money they need to
keep growing a massive amount of agency
exchanges hands so now off to Scott this
League of Legends slot and overwatch
League slot infinite sin charge and hex
hands over a lot of the day-to-day
responsibilities to optic J now hex says
the reason he did this was so that after
years of running this company he could
go back to what he
really love the reason that I chose to
step back was to create content and have
fun right without the worry of
spreadsheets and without the worry of
any of that [ __ ]
yeah okay and that's kind of where
everything broke down so as with most
multi-million dollar investments this
thing wasn't perfect off the jungle and
according to hex money was just being
spent in the wrong places I remember
walking in seeing the allegiance plague
and I pointed I am what the [ __ ] is that
why is there another team's flag in my
offices right because I put to the point
they hadn't told me that they were gonna
pick up all these other teams for
whatever [ __ ] reason right and I walk
in and I and I look at Jay and I'm able
to it he's like you just did that
and I was just like no I need an
explanation as to what the [ __ ] this is
right and I see all these people and
immediately I'm just like we don't need
this many people right
we don't Oh what right and this is where
the dark side of this sort of suit and
tie mergers and acquisitions business
that's so popular in eSports right now
shows its face and the fact is despite
hex trying to make his opinions known
about his baby infinite didn't have to
listen to him nothing went smoothly
it was always seeming to be optic versus
corporate and so with the organ of worse
place than it's ever been and hex and
infinite not getting along they start to
entertain a sale of the optic name and
the LCS lot to Immortals gaming now to
say this would be horrible news for the
Greenwald the fans of optic gaming would
be an understatement
you see if this acquisition ended up
taking place the optic named in League
of Legends would be switched to
immortals and the only remnants of the
optic gaming name would exist in the Cod
League where immortals had bought a spot
previously and notably this would mean
hex would have almost no connection to
the brand that he's been working his
entire life to build up the J tried to
theosis him and so as you might imagine
hex was a post and he put together an
offer to buy back optic from infinite
and beat out immortals
let me get optic back I wasn't asking
for a discount I was I was trying to
make them some money so they you know
whatever
we gave it a good run but as we now know
hex lost that battle he tried he failed
and optik just frankly doesn't really
exist in the same capacity anymore and
so this brings me to a couple weeks ago
where hex is now announced that he's
moving to NRG to become a co CEO and
help run their Call of Duty franchise
everything that we've heard from hex
since then has been thankful he's
thankful for the greenwall and
everything he built during all of those
years adopted he says that he doesn't
regret anything and despite the way
everything ended up he looks back proud
you are not gonna get rid of me until
it's time for me to go so you are with
you stuck with me you're stuck on every
single adventure that I go on you're
stuck on every single project that I'm
gonna be a part of and for that I thank
you from the bottom and that brings me
to frankly the bitter end of my story
hex and optic 2 names that were
synonymous with eSports for years are no
longer one and honestly that [ __ ]
sucks this is really one of the first
prominent casualties of this sort of
corporate esports roller coaster that
we've been on for the last few years on
the surface people buying and selling
companies and 30 million in dollar
investments there and a Series B funding
around there it all looks great but the
fact is when things get corporate
there's always gonna be consequences and
this time it was the death in the green
wall thanks for watching if you want
more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you will
find anywhere else
hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]